idris debbie was president of chad for
three decades
on the day of the news of his death it
was announced his son muhammad will lead
the country for the next 18 months
as head of the transitional military
council abdul rahim yunes
the head of the government airline
al-wasad party says there are reasons
for the military to take charge
it's understandable that the
constitution says the speaker of
parliament should be in charge
but it's also understandable why the
military is the one in charge
what needs to happen now is a dialogue
to bring other parties and groups to
form a joint military civilian council
to lead the country to democratic
elections idris debbie who led the
country since 1990
died from injuries sustained while
leading his soldiers against the rebel
front for change and conquered group in
the northern region of canaan
based in libya the group launched an
attack on a border position on april
11th
days of fighting to push them back left
more than 300 of the rebels dead
and almost 150 captured the group says
there's no way they'll accept debbie's
son as chad's leader
vasila declaration official chad is not
a monarchy
there can be no dynastic devolution of
power in our country
the national resistance forces from the
front for change
and concord in chad are right now on
their way towards
germanna with confidence but above all
with courage and determination
at 37 mohamed debbie an army officer is
now the youngest leader in the african
continent
14 other military officers are also in
the council which stated that a
transitional government will be put in
place
and that they're not seeking permanent
power
we wanted to reassure the public that
the members of the transitional military
council
will hand over power to civilian
government after free and democratic
elections within 18 months
chad's constitution which has been
dissolved by the military council
states that the speaker of parliament is
to lead the country in the event of the
death of the president
so some opposition parties are calling
the formation of a military council a
coup
it's not only political parties that
have split over the idea of a
transitional military council
leading the country following the death
of idris debbie while early election
results showed he'd won nearly 80
of the votes in the weeks leading up to
the election
hundreds in the capital demonstrated
calling for change and many boycotted
the elections that ended with debbie
winning a sixth term
with debbie's death chad's residents are
divided between mourning him
and denouncing the council that's
replaced him
the military council says it's going to
form an interim cabinet in the coming
days
and has called political parties and
armed groups for dialogue
it's not yet clear who's going to agree
to be present at any talks
heber morgan al-jazeera and jamaina